ja mein vater war tatsächlich der lebt
in einem altenheim in einer
altersresidenz ihr seit anderthalb
jahren und ich muss vorausschicken dass
das überhaupt keine fehler gemacht hat
es hat also bis mitte diesen jahres
überhaupt keinen einzigen corona fall
gegeben insofern kann man davon ausgehen
dass die hygienemaßnahmen dort
eigentlich sehr gut funktioniert haben
nun hat mit mitte diesen dezembers und
letzten dezember gab es zwei gewinner
fälle und corona verbreitete sich
irrsinnig schnell und mein vater sitzt
jetzt in einem hotspot am 27 sollte er
geimpft werden und das tolle an ihm ist
er sofort gesagt als es um den impfstoff
geht ich bin dabei ist die impfung
sofort her damit
er hatte dann wirklich also an diesem 27
seinen termin aber es kam niemand
und am 28 war dann klar es gibt einen
großen ausbruch im heim und jetzt sind
mein vater menschen im hotspot er ist
nach wie vor negativ auch heute negativ
getestet aber ich frage mich natürlich
und das fragen sich viele angehörige die
mit sicherheit auch schon in den
impfstrategien mit drin waren und die
auch schon geben werden sollten wo ist
der impfstoff jetzt warum ist niemand
ins haus meines vaters gekommen warum
hat man nicht einfach raus geholt um ihm
den lebensrettenden tipps zu geben und
da wäre jetzt schon eine woche geimpft
das ist
ich finde das ist ohne worte und die
menschen die in altenheimen sind ich
betreue hier mein vater schon etwas
länger und habe viel einblick in die
heime die sitzen da und warten darauf
und bekommen dann gesagt ja du warst du
auf der liste aber jetzt tue so gut und
das finde ich ganz ganz schwierig meint
merken dass seine energie nachlässt also
nach 22 jahren betragen alleine auf dem
zimmer sitzen mit dem versprechen dass
der hemmstoff kommt wenn ich das eine
tragödien und zwar für alle anderen die
es betrifft